[Music]
hi I'm Eric an engineering manager at
Google working on open source
integrations for Google cloud platform
this is the first in a short series of
videos talking about some of the great
open-source tools by Hashi Corp and how
they can be used with Google cloud
platform each video will focus on a
specific tool but will be part of an
overall demo that will keep adding to
with each new video in the series and
over hangouts I have with me today are
Tamiya começo a Googler based in Sydney
and Chris Roberts an engineer at hashey
Corp based in Portland Oregon thanks for
joining me today fellows here's the
background story for this series each
video will have a different set of guest
speakers but let's imagine they're part
of a small game studio and are working
on their next project a 1980s retro
style space game but updated to play on
the web with multiplayer support it's
been designed to have a separate
JavaScript front-end and back-end server
written in the go programming language
through the next few videos we'll follow
the project along from the development
phase up through a demo to the CEO and
then finally the big launch but for
today's video we're still in the
development phase of the project with a
couple of developers actively working on
writing the code so where do the hacci
Corp tools fit into this today we'll
start with vagrant Chris can you tell us
a little bit about vagrant and what
problems it solves sure
bayern is a tool primarily used by
software developers it provides an easy
and repeatable way to create custom
development environments Baker has been
around for a long time and brings
together the well-known worlds and PM's
and operating systems along with some of
the same patterns you may have heard
about with docker but without having to
adopt a new container centric world
thanks Chris I think we've all heard
stories or experience this ourselves of
working at places where developers
create their environments by copying and
pasting a bunch of shell commands from
some internal wiki page vagrant
essentially replaces those setup
instructions with a single configuration
file that can be put under version
control and treated just like your code
correct me if I'm wrong but a common use
case is for developers to use vagrant to
spin up local VMs if they have
VirtualBox from VMware installed yes
that's correct
with local VMs the developer isn't
cluttering up their host operating
system with a bunch of extra software or
having to run a specific operating
system it's easy to create and destroy
these VMs to
well concern to get tricky low is when
developers want to collaborate using a
local VM and while vagrant does have a
share feature that may not always be a
viable option so they can use the remote
the end that they can share this is
where it G CP integration with vagrant
comes in Google cloud platform has many
different services ranging from big data
and machine learning all the way down to
infrastructure offerings such as our vm
service compute engine let's get started
with how developers can use vagrant to
spin up a shared GCE VM first go to
vagrant up comm and download the version
for your local system next go to cloud
at google.com slash free - trial to
create a Google cloud platform account
if you don't already have one
next you'll need to enable the Google
compute engine API a service account and
a corresponding JSON credential file
will need to be created as well now
we'll spin up a Google compute engine
instance with my hyperspace video game
and develop an environment ready to go
don't forget to install the vagrant
Google driver using vagrant plug in
command I'll do that with a vagrant up
command with Google provider specified
of course for this to work I'll need to
create my vagrant file first Chris can
you walk us through our vagrant file
sure first we define the provider
information to access the GCE
API this includes a project ID client
email and user information next we
provide details for the type of instance
we want vagrant to create and set the
SSH information to allow access using
vagrant sync folders we're able to push
the local source code to the new
instance and finally a provisioning
script is used to create the new
instance here a simple shell provision
runs an inline script on the reload
instance vagrant also supports other
provisioners like chef and puppet for
more complex instance configuration now
let's see how the GCE instance is coming
along okay now that the vagrant app has
finished you can see in the console that
I have a new GC VM running when I click
on its public IP address you can see
that the game is up and working
vengan GCE make a great combination
first in areas like this when you have
more
developers needing access to the same VM
GCU will store users SSH keys in
metadata and those keys are propagated
to the VM to allow remote access yes
with a quick vagrant SSH you can see
there are multiple users in the home
directory each with their own SSH key to
access the VM you can also see that
artem source code was copied at the VM
and served hyperspace directory as was
specified in his vacuum file so that was
pretty quick almost as fast as spinning
up a local VM yeah that looked really
easy now for those looking to get
started for their first time where's the
best place for them to learn more sure
to get started with vagrant or to learn
more check out vagrant thanks for
watching check out our last video in the
series playlist and don't forget to
subscribe to the channel